tras la polémica alec Baldwin y los
productores de la película rust han
llegado a un acuerdo con la familia de
Alina hutchen la directora de fotografía
a la que el actor mató accidentalmente
de un disparo en pleno set de rodaje nos
complace
civil presentado en nombre de la familia
de la directora de fotografía Alina
hutchens agradecemos a todos los que han
contribuido a la resolución de esta
Trágica y dolorosa situación el marido
de Alina Matthew hatchins anunció que el
rodaje se reanudará en enero con los
actores originales y con él como
productor ejecutivo no tengo ningún
interés en entrar en recriminaciones o
atribución de culpas a los productores o
al Señor Baldwin todos creemos que la
muerte de Alina fue un terrible
accidente Baldwin Estaba ensayando con
un arma cuando dispara una bala que
alcanzó a la cineasta ucraniana
a pesar de que Balvin ha negado su
responsabilidad los abogados de la
familia le recriminaron no revisar si el
arma tenía munición antes de disparar
apuntar a una persona y pulsar el
gatillo
a pesar de La retirada de la demanda
civil Baldwin y otros miembros del
elenco podrían enfrentar cargos penales
todo mientras Los investigadores
intentan determinar quién cargó el arma
con munición real